good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
hump day good day it's a beautiful
day because thco is back in studio ready
to celebrate hump day in style he's
looking good
smelling good and i'm just so excited to
have this
precious energy to carry us through yeah
and it wouldn't be a hump day without
theo so make sure to hump someone you
love whether that's your partner
it's so important and you know in this
unprecedented time it is more important
than ever to like keep the traditions of
hump day
alive i totally agree it's a weekly
reminder to hump it out
and just it's also a weekly reminder for
if we take a different perspective
it's a weekly reminder for you to just
pretty much like spread love and know
and like appreciate the people in your
life who you love
you know yeah yeah that's all i'm saying
yeah i think it's a beautiful day and
it's a beautiful reminder it's a
beautiful reminder it is a beautiful day
it's supposed to be a major snowstorm
here in new york oh it's going to start
trickling in this afternoon
it hasn't started so i've like a lot to
do before the snow starts because once
the sun starts i'm like
completely out of commission useless i
know but it's so weird having a
snowstorm after a year of being in
lockdown because it's like there's no
difference it's like
oh i don't need to go out and get canned
foods because i have them right no and
oh that's true it's like you know it's
like
this is nothing this is what one day of
not leaving house
no but it's like we're also like not
everyone's still working from home so
it's like
oh cool it's snowing outside from home
with snowflakes so what
yeah well except for us because yeah
we're here delivering
yeah we have an amazing show for you
guys today it is wednesday which means
two things one
our second bachelorette recap of the
week will be in the tv recap segment
and it will be dear toasters our advice
segment which we do every wednesday and
if you ever want to write in you can
email us
dear toasters gmail.com i'm so excited
to hear what you guys have cooked up for
us today
me as well me as well as i say this
every wednesday but
during quarantine i literally say this
every wednesday dear toasters has become
one of my favorite parts of the week
yeah it really has it's probably because
it's also hump day that's true i know
you're gonna hum someone you love 100
getting a haircut today i'm just like
you know when you have weeks where you
just like
take care of business and for me it's
like any week before i'm going to
actually do something yeah
um i'm so jealous you're getting a
haircut i'm having one of those weeks
too like
wax manicure dentist oh that's a big one
how did it go
you know what okay so it was in a lot of
ways worse than i expected but in a lot
of ways better than i expected
in terms of pain and uncomfortability
and like how i thought i would have like
50 root canals since literally
neglecting my oral
health um i didn't have that so that's
where i was positively surprised
the second thing that kind of
disappointed me in a lot of ways it was
like so much
more you know involved than i remember
like getting all these
x-rays done like seems so unnecessary
like just tell me if i have a cavity you
know like
and putting the machine in my mouth was
so painful and just took longer than i
expected so
it was i overall i net it out even it
wasn't as bad
i was just scared i was gonna be in pain
and like literally have to get an
emergency root canal but she actually
said she made a point to ask
what kind of brush are you and by the
way we don't have an ad for bruce today
but she literally said like
what kind of brush do you use electric
and i'm like yes a bruise she's like you
brush so well that's that brush for you
all you have to do to brush well is just
hold it to your
brush and let the bruce do the work yeah
and use coat toast that your teeth do
get shinier scientists say
but if you use the code i also was just
like on my instagram stories talking
about you know my
disdain for the dentist and people were
just being so funny i guess like
most adults like it's like you're either
one type of adult or the other like
either you
go to the dentist like every six months
or you literally neglect your oral
health for years at a time yeah and
that's me
i've been both of those people and now
i'm one that goes all
like regularly because i don't like what
i have to do when it when i wait too
long it's bad news but i just i think
there's people have different kinds of
teeth like i am very my teeth are very
high maintenance yours are almost no by
very long
she like couldn't believe i hadn't been
to the dentist in so long it's like yes
yes so proud but i got a cleaning i feel
like my breath is better
that's good yeah i was telling her like
the only real problem i have is like if
i don't eat for a while like which is
rare
i have like the worst [ __ ] breath and
it's beyond bad breath it's like duty in
the throat
and she said i might have just needed a
cleaning so here i am
do i look different that's so funny and
i was all day making ben
smell my breath i'm like is it better he
was like no
no i don't think that teeth cleaning
makes it that much better
no she said it's also probably like a
digestive thing but it's like coming
from your stomach she said like stop
eating like [ __ ] and
you might have better breath now i've
eaten all different ways in my life and
the breath is bad no matter how you
slice it
you know it's funny it's like we've been
in the morning toast for two years three
almost
going on three on three and we will
still always in our souls be the morning
breath
yeah for so we're talking about breath
always um so we've been amazing show for
you guys today and i think um if you
have nothing else to catch the world up
on
i think we could get right into it
because we have like a lot of think
ground to cover sure okay go oh what
were you going to say though
i was just going to um say how like
yesterday i spent all day working on my
cameo
and it was so rewarding both financially
and emotionally are you enjoying being
part of the cameo family you know i am
because i would say like 90 out of 100
of the cameos that i got yesterday were
from one sister to another sister
it was a sibling you know moment and for
that we have no choice but to stand
that's so exciting i just like being a
gift that makes me feel special you know
no it's it's such a rewarding experience
for
everyone involved and i'm glad that you
are on the cameo train
cameo family i look forward to seeing
how it progresses
woohoo so without further ado it is time
for the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
noom where getting in shape doesn't have
to be about losing a specific amount of
weight or a magic number on the scale
it's about building healthier habits and
feeling better about yourself if fitting
into your favorite pair of jeans is your
goal then great but there are many
reasons why you might want to practice
self-care
and every person is different so what is
new it is a habit-changing solution that
helps users learn to develop a new
relationship with food
through personalized courses it's based
in psychology so noom teaches you why
you do the things you do
and empowers you with the tools you need
to break bad habits and replace them
with better ones
nume is not a diet it's a healthy and
easy to stick to way of life where no
food is considered good
bad or off limits they teach you
moderation and it can be used in
conjunction with many pre-existing
popular diets which i know is what you
do and now you're getting all your
friends on board is that right
yes i am nemo.com telling everyone about
it because i have
loved doing the noon program and it's
the best place i think to start if you
don't know that much about
what it takes to reach your goals you
know whatever those goals may be i think
noon is the perfect place to start to
really
learn about how the human body your body
and i think most of the numerous would
agree that one of the
best parts about it is their accurate
and the biggest online food database
available
that lets you track your meal habits
visualize portion sizes and see calorie
density at a glance
and since we're all strapped for time
noom is just asking you to commit to 10
minutes a day for yourself
and you're human so if you go off track
there's absolutely no shaming
they just give you tips to help you get
back on track tomorrow you can chat with
the gold specialist and the newm
community
to get and give help to people going
through the same thing noom says you
don't have to change it all in one day
small steps make big progress sign up
for your trial today at noom
n o m dot com slash
toast what do you have to lose visit
noom.com
toast to start your trial today that's n
o
o m dot com slash toast
love it okay first story really big news
that broke yesterday the duke and
duchess of sussex are becoming
podcasters prince harry and megan
have inked an exclusive multi-year deal
with spotify through a newly formed
production company archwell audio
together they plan to host and produce
podcasts that uplift
and entertain audiences the partnership
will kick off later this month with a
holiday special hosted by the couple
that will feature inspirational stories
spotify owned studio gimlet will produce
the show
in partnership with archwell audio harry
and megan said in a statement that quote
what we love about podcasting is that
reminds all of us to take a moment and
to really listen
to connect to one another without
distraction with the challenges of 2020
there has never been a more important
time to do so
because when we hear each other and hear
each other's stories we are reminded how
of how interconnected we all are okay i
just have to say and i have a lot of
thoughts on this but like
the statement is like a little insulting
like just call it what it is like you
needed the money like
for sure and it's like 2020 is ending
now so we got through twenty
existing podcasts and we got late we got
through twenty without you 2020 without
you
so don't come in in december and try and
help like
i just the statement is like a little
insulting to our intelligence it's like
we wanted to do we believe in pot you
have never listened to a podcast in your
[ __ ] life
like just let's call it what it is it is
you gotta work i totally respect it yeah
no
like just the emphasis on 2020 when
you're literally putting out your
podcast in the last week of 2020 yeah
like
the other podcast got us through it's
silly it's silly
but as this being their next step i
actually think this is a great move for
them i think
i see this from two perspectives i think
we've been like kind of monitoring what
spotify has been doing this whole year
we've been talking about you know them
doing addison ray's podcast
kim did a social justice michelle obama
and i think this is like a huge get for
them a huge
get for the for the podcasting community
but spotify has kind of been on this
journey we've been watching them all
year
to like really dominate the podcasting
space joe rogan
so this is huge for them congrats to the
spotify team for getting you know
archwell on board
and now for megan and harry it's like it
must be so nice for them to like
they don't they they do they've done now
i think three
big deals this year and since leaving
and like needing to work and live
and what's the third one there's netflix
now spotify megan had that disney plus
voiceover thing
oh true and um i think that was it they
have a netflix
deal netflix did you say no yeah so they
just have like these three or four like
huge benchmark deals
and it's like they just do like a deal a
quarter and they live this like
magnificent life yeah for sure but i
wondered i was actually thinking about
the two of them the other day before
this announcement came out and i was
like
they were like the first big story of
2020 that they were exiting
the royal family and like obvious i
think that like coronavirus has
been really damaging no to their plans
like
i think they must have had like big big
plans to step out and they were going to
like
you know do it with red carpets met gala
this is that
and they could have had some big big
hands too they could have had some big
big hands along with their big big plans
and
i think they had to recalibrate what
their move was going to be and i wonder
if 2020 wasn't the year that it was
would they have ever
turned into the podcasting realm and i
feel like no well okay so you just
raised a really really interesting point
that i think goes back to what the world
is kind of divided on when it comes to
mexican and harry so
either coronavirus was the best thing or
the worst thing
no wait let me let me finish okay
because there's a certain amount of
people who truly
and i don't even know where i stand
because i read some of the book like i
i don't know where i stand on megan
harry but there are two ways of thinking
when it comes to megan and harry and
their exit from the royal family
the first way of thinking is like they
are thirst monsters they use the royal
family
this is what megan's always wanted they
just want to be famous and be in america
and like do netflix
so if that's the case yes 2020 was the
worst year for them to have left and
i'm sure they're regretting all their
decisions but there's not so much i
don't think they're regretting their
decision because they're just like
they're they're like recalibrating
there's also a group of people
who and if you read the book it was very
convincing that this is the way that it
all happened that it was really just
like
too much for them too much for megan too
much for the baby so toxic he was never
gonna be an actual
you know um king yeah so like what's the
point
and this was so toxic and this was the
best thing for their family and for
their mental health and then having a
break this year
was best for their mental health right
so either it depends on how you see the
message situation
because either kovid and quarantine was
the most incredible thing to have like a
literally a gift from god exactly what
megan was asking for
or literally a gift from satan exactly
the opposite of what megan was asking
for it's just how you see the situation
i think just like
everything else it's a bit of both i
think for a lot of people there has been
a silver lining in quarantine you know
getting back to what's important
spending time with the people that you
love
having quality time with people that you
wouldn't have had it with otherwise and
i feel like they can definitely see that
side of it but i think on the business
side
they still have to work and it
whatever plans that they were making
might have been stymied
by this year and by the way they're
probably making just as if not more
there's actually been so much money like
poured into media this year because
so many people are like changing their
habits so i think they're probably
making the same if not more money is
whatever their og plan was
but it's just not as prestigious it's
not the mcallen red carpet it's the
podcasting
um pod potty awards you know yeah no i
think
they they're still like doing well and
they're
they're moving with the times i just i
think that they had some like really
glamorous plans
and i don't know everything's now
virtual i feel like they're always
popping up on like
zooms on a zoom and it's like that's not
super glamorous that's not
like x-ray it's not red carpet can
stairs yeah megan and harry stepping out
like
you know yeah that's true you know what
i mean i'm also kind of glad we were
like spared that temporarily
but they really do know how to take a
picture like do you remember how much we
like
pictures over the last that was like
their last royal event she wore that
blue dress and i was holding the
umbrella and it was like
literally movie magic yeah and i think a
lot of their plans for this year like
did um include those moments which were
taken out that's
very very possible you know but anyways
i think this is such exciting news like
this is literally
the craziest royal podcast news like the
podcast industry is officially
royalty or it couldn't be more exciting
for podcasters yeah congrat
good job spotify for getting this done
like thank you for all from all the
podcasters around the world to spotify
thank you for legitimizing our business
like i have the same job as prince harry
guess what i have the same job as meghan
markle like we're queens
no we are qui literally we're
um also i like so the description of
their podcast sounds like they're
telling inspirational stories and it's a
little vague
but i'm sure like i'm just gonna say
their voices they're
i don't know where they're gonna have
some other people on telling stories
i'm i'm excited to listen to it and hear
what it's about i'm curious as to the
format as well and i also feel like with
the podcast you know there's so much
time to fill in talking you really do
get a sense of a person's personality
and so and you got to get a little
personal yeah no and i feel like we're
gonna
learn more about the two of them on a
personal level i'm excited for that
so they're they're holding company or
whatever it's called archwell arch
obviously for archie
yeah what's well they've been another
one on the way wellington
they're living well maybe yes they are
with that i don't know spotify money i'm
sure there's like
it means something is significant taylor
swift of them i know and how tnn of them
to do a podcast
and produce others yes oh is that what
they're doing yes
oh my god kind of like copying our
format oh my god
i mean we love to we love to see it glad
we can inspire other small podcasters
[Laughter]
all right you guys are enough to laugh a
lot
[Laughter]
anyways i think this is that's why we do
what we do you know like smaller
creators who like look up top
it's like it's really crazy if you think
about 2020 like they
they started 2020 as royalty and now
they're with us
they're with us welcome welcome it's
really great
you're gonna love it here it's a great
medium
talk about a fall from grace even though
like this is really prestigious it's
just funny like
yeah it's money money money
okay ready for our next story yes tom
cruise is screaming at his film crew
members over coveted rules
in leaked audio i have a lot of thoughts
about this okay i'm gonna give you
the the quotes a furious tom cruise torn
to workers who broke coven 19 rules on
set of mission impossible
screaming if i see you doing it again
you're [ __ ] gone
he has been working tirelessly behind
the scenes to enforce tight social
distancing rules during the filming
which is taking place in britain
and he flew into a rage after spotting
two of the crew member members
standing within six feet of each other
they were both looking at a camera
there's an audio tape that captured him
shouting it's two and a half minutes
and it's worth the listen it says quote
if i see
if i see you do it again you're [ __ ]
gone and if anyone in this crew does it
that's it and you too and you too and
you don't you ever [ __ ] do it again
it was just absolutely nuts and i saw a
lot of people i wanted to read like what
the vibe was on social media because
as far as i know before this video like
who is tom cruise to me
you know he is like the financier of
scientology like a toxic cult
and that's pretty much like oh and he
was like mean to katie holmes like
that's really what i know about him
so i'm like neglectful no not
reticent yeah reticent to like you know
label him a hero but
i was looking online and a lot of people
were like praising him for taking
the pandemic so seriously now i just
have to say like
i don't really care what really whatever
you're saying like you can't talk to
people that way like
his tone and what he was actually saying
was so [ __ ] nasty
especially like think about it like he's
a big time celebrity and these are
people who work on a movie set like
there's
there is that dynamic where like people
who are celebrities i think that they're
better than the people that they work
with
and his tone was just so unacceptable
like there no matter what's going on
like there's
there's never an okay time to speak to
people that way like i'm sorry ever no
matter what you're saying
no yes i'm glad that um tom cruise is
taking the pandemic seriously and i am
but in the video if you listen he's not
really
upset because people will get sick
he's upset because he doesn't want the
movie to get shut down and he thinks
and he said not in the exact words but
that he's like the whole industry is
like on his back
in this movie yeah this time it's on him
to get the industry back together it's
like
take a seat tom cruise he relax grandpa
they're back in hollywood making movies
right now because of us we are creating
thousands of jobs you [ __ ]
that's it no apologies you can tell it
to the people that are losing their
[ __ ] homes because our industry
industry
is shut down we are not shutting this
[ __ ] moving down is that understood
if i see it again you're [ __ ] gone
there was also a line about how like
he was responsible for bringing movies
back and it was just like a
i don't know i i i don't see i'm not
just
jumping to like give him credit for
taking the pandemic series i haven't
seen other people's thoughts on this but
when i read
what he said and how he said it no like
it's so unnecessary two people standing
together looking at a camera
to film a movie that like he to working
for him
yeah like are you joking and by the way
in terms of breaking covered protocols
it would be one thing if people were
like not wearing their masks like
there's a party out cast party on each
other's faces but like because they
stood
less than six feet away from each other
to do their jobs i'm sorry this
seems like a complete overreaction like
and no you know what maybe
maybe this is you know movie making is a
non-essential business it really is no
way so i'm glad that all these hollywood
actors are all
gung-ho about getting back to work while
like servers and restaurant owners are
just out of business i just don't
[ __ ] feel bad for you tom cruise no
i just don't i don't feel bad at all i
feel like so many celebrities or
actors are getting back to work and i
think movie making is a non-essential
business and there are so many other
businesses quintessential
that aren't working and so i just think
this is like such a
karen cruz move oh my god karen
cruz yes like i just this story bothered
me and like i saw people praising him
online i'm like why do we care first of
all
tom cruise like what we know about him
it's like he literally
is the worst human being ever he's a nut
he finances scientology which is known
to be
like the most corrupt abusive
organization so
first of all i'm not running to like you
know tweet about how much i love tom
cruise second of all
he's [ __ ] yelling at hard-working
people on this video and
okay great he's taking the pandemic
seriously not because he cares about the
spread of the virus because he cares
about his movie coming out like
which is the most non-essential business
of all time like i just i can't be
bothered
to like give one more brain cell and
give one more shred of a [ __ ]
about tom cruise right or about like
this
in general yeah no it's like sorry i
don't feel bad for celebrities i do feel
bad for the people who chose to work in
the film right that's who he's yelling
at
right i feel bad for them right like
they know what's at stake they're the
ones who are attacking
them who haven't been working they're
the last six months and who haven't been
able to feed their families and now they
come to work do you have yell daddy
and tom cruise [ __ ] for doing
their job and standing near a camera to
make [ __ ] tom cruise
more money and more famous it's so
hypocritical it's so hypocritical
oh my god justice for everyone who was
in that video getting yelled at totally
i'm like sweating oh my god yeah
i chose the wrong day to wear like a
chunky knit
i should have warned you should have
worn my tank top
um okay next story pastor jamal bryan is
reacting
to the real house as a potomac reunion
accusations and cheating on gisele and
by reacting
i mean like he's tweeting and talking
about it but not really talking
about it because he um posted a cryptic
instagram message
imploring his followers to remain
unbothered he said give no energy
to anything that doesn't add to your joy
align with your purpose
or pay any of your bills he captioned
the post of a man sitting under running
water while enjoying a meal
be at peace okay like i guess that could
also
that like that could be pertaining to
the drama but it could also be just like
a church post you know like that's
something a pastor would post
yeah any time of day i just feel like
that sort of post
is like more confirmation you know
because
if it was untrue he would say it was
untrue because that's the easiest thing
to do a hundred percent
and if there was like like baseless
accusations running around
not even like your inner circle the
whole country about you like
even the most peaceful pastor couldn't
not respond
yeah because it's dragon and jamal's the
whole business is his name and so it's
like if these really things are things
are untrue
and you're just being dragged through
them i'd like of course you're going to
respond right no response
is a response in a lot of ways yeah this
is a response and i i feel like it lines
up with
like there's nothing in here that does
that says that this is untrue
right give no energy to anything that
doesn't add to your joy align with your
purpose or pay any of your bills no i'm
100
sure that everything monique said and
everything in monique's binder
in general is completely 100 factual
yeah
um but also i do agree with that do give
no energy to anything that doesn't add
to your joy align with your purpose or
pay any of your bills no that sounds
like an amazing like brainy quotes
card no but i just feel like the more
you live and learn like that's those are
the priorities oh yeah
joy purpose and bills and minding your
own damn business
100 which is a huge pillar of my life
100 okay our next story online is
reporting that kim and kanye are like
oh my god this article is like so
[ __ ]
inflammatory is that the right word yeah
but don't you think it's weird that it
comes from e while the kardashians like
are still part of the evening no
honestly when i read it i was like oh he
is salty as [ __ ] because like
first of all it's not uncommon for like
these fake celebrity news outlets
to have like sources who say random
things and that never means that they're
true but when it came to the kardashians
the e
he never did that because they always
had one ear with chris
or yeah a direct line into the family so
like this seems like a bitter move to me
i'm not gonna lie and i don't believe it
and i'm really done with like everyone
trying to take down kim and connie's
marriage like
we have seen time after time like
they're not going anywhere so like just
stop
yeah but the rumors are that kim and
kanye are doing their own thing they
spend a lot of time apart and they are
focused on things that are important to
them separately oh my god my foot
are you okay you know when like you're
wearing a big wait is that the foot
that's on the cover of
girl with no job.com slash book oh my
god how did you know
the first time getting recognized oh my
god this is her first time getting
recognized yes i don't know if you guys
notice
it's a little more photoshopped but my
foot does make it appear appearance on
the cover of my book which comes out so
soon you guys
january 26 2021 you lift your leg a
little higher because your foot just
looks well that's a great question
can i your foot looks so funny right now
and small
[Laughter]
girlwithnojob.combook is the link where
you can get my
award-winning book and the award that i
got is the theo's mom award which is
really really prestigious
my book is called girls no job the crazy
beautiful life of an instagram thirst
monster
and it's essentially the story of my
life from start to finish but
not finished because that would imply
that i died start to now start to now
all about you know starting our business
being in college
becoming comedian getting cancelled lots
of interesting things i get a lot of uh
get a lot of questions over the years
and they're all pretty much in this book
even if you listen to the podcast a lot
and you think you know everything about
me there's so much more to know even my
best friend
i had my friend jason reed who have
known since like the ninth grade
and he pretty much knows everything
about me and has been there for
everything and
he told me what he loved you know among
many things in the book was that
um he didn't know like most of this
stuff about me you know yeah
um but why don't you put your foot down
now no it's okay um
what i was trying to say before you so
graciously offered to promote my book
is you know when you're wearing like a
big chunky boot with a sock and like
your foot is so [ __ ] itchy
oh do you ever get that i thought you
were going to say sock sliding syndrome
oh no no i'm just having like itchy foot
ichi food
inside my boots and it's really annoying
but i think i got the each
out okay good yeah no but sometimes when
you have an itchy foot like it's you
also are tickling yourself it's so crazy
no no no there's a difference between an
itch and a tickle tip
for me i'm so ticklish even just
thinking about it
you must be like the worst at getting
pedicures oh my god the worst we're
always cracking up
yeah um what was the story oh jamal no
kim and kanye like
separate lives um i don't believe it
like i'm just
i'm just i'm not into the fake news
industry you know no i totally agree and
also like whether
even if say it were true like do what
you got to do
yeah sometimes you need a little
personal space 100
like this is just so traumatic okay like
i take a break from ben all the time
it's like i go out to lunch with my
friends like
yeah what are we talking like stop using
such vague words yeah totally
what's a break yeah they're like not
saying anything but they're like trying
to like they're trying to start stuff
they're trying to start stuff with a
family that was very good to them for
way too long
agreed are you ready and they could
stand to be a little bit more gracious
i'm ready for our fifth and final story
because it's it's about being good it's
not philanthropy news okay
i don't know if you've seen mckenzie
scott yes mackenzie scott who is the
ex-wife of jeff bezos
reveals that she has given away nearly
4.2 billion dollars in the last four
months
isn't that crazy that's crazy i mean she
is
well i don't know if now after she gave
away 4 billion but when she and jeff
bezos got divorced she was like the
second richest
person in the world right after jeff
bezos i'm sure that like she still is
and she gave away
that much money to 384 organizations
in america she wrote like an article for
medium explaining you know
her philanthropic ways and i just think
that that is remarkable
queen queen queen she did we had
reported i think when she initially got
her
settlement she was gonna join the the
giving pledge which is like what a lot
of the richest people do to like donate
half of their wealth
um and it's wonderful to see her doing
it can you just imagine like having so
much money that like you actually don't
need all of it
yeah you know like that like in your
lifetime and like your children
you couldn't even wow iconic iconic and
we stand a philanthropic queen doing the
most with what she has and we live for
it
and i kind of also live for her i'm like
telling everyone about it you know
because yeah
there's like this weird and it's a
feeling in 2020 like it's gotten even
more weird there's like this thing where
it's like if you're a public figure
and you donate to charity and you
publicize it like you did it for the
wrong reasons
but then if you don't publicize it you
get so much [ __ ]
for not being charitable and it's like
so which one is it
how do i win yeah no i think you know it
just depends on
the way that people go about it and i
feel like with this
amount of money the it it should be
known and also
she um no i'm i'm all for celebrities
and public figures like sharing their
um philanthropic efforts if that means
they do more of it like why are we
shaming people for sharing their charity
i don't care that it's like it's not
real charity you don't tell anybody like
i don't care like people are getting the
money great
yeah thanks taylor swift donated 13 000
to two different moms
last week yeah all right love to see it
um okay let's dive into our tv recap
let's dive right in the bachelorette
hometowns were last night and by
hometowns i mean different corners of
the
la quinta in palm springs you know what
credit where it's too i think they made
the best out of a bad situation i
thought the dates were all very
different from one another
very fun they really brought in like all
of their skills from wood shop
and started building sets it was really
like a camp production
yeah you know and there was a camper on
the set yes and
brendan's the camper in me was happy to
see campers flourishing and thriving on
the set of the bachelorette all right so
let's just like bang out each one who
went first
brendan brandon and it was very good i
mean even
the thing is like for me i think brennan
is the man for her of all the guys there
for a bunch of different reasons but at
the rose ceremony i was kind of like
she gave him the rose because she didn't
want to reward ben because he like gave
her nothing this week and she's done
pulling things out of him
and she was almost like it was a like a
consolation prize
for brennan so i don't really feel like
she's there with brendan i thought maybe
during the date but just the way she
acted at the rose ceremony proved that
like
he's not top two material oh interesting
on the date i was like oh this is really
real this could be it and then all the
other dates i felt the same way so
yeah and i forgot about the first one
and then i circled back to who i thought
was the most real
and i think zack c is who she's going to
choose
me too that's what i said um but so
nothing really to report from brendan's
day like it was all cute and lovely and
his brother looks just like him
oh by the way actually i didn't want to
say one thing and i think brendan is
such a peach i'm like every time he
talks about his brother like he just
cries like i feel that's so hard and
his brother was so cute and like they
were both just like sitting around
crying and i just love them
yeah no i actually felt like these um
hometowns were really emotional for the
families because i think everything is
heightened this year in general
but i do think that like families who
don't talk about like their emotions a
lot when you go on tv and like
you they literally are asking you these
questions that are corny at the time but
they make you
open up and like just when zach c like
had the sit down with his mom and like
he took the time to just be like i love
you so much like it wasn't even about
tasha anymore they were just talking
about their feelings was zack sees mom
the blonde one yeah yeah she was
hilarious she was so
cute and it was just like bursting she
said she loves the bachelor yes i felt
like he was just like saying
everything to her that he like regretted
never not having said enough
and it became less about like is like
about jesus which i mean it's always
about tatian like literally everyone
says
oh my god oh my god uh zach's dad was in
love with her
and so was uh ivan's dad everyone
everyone's in love with her but like i
don't know i feel like all these
families just had a nice moment where
they were able to like
tell each other that they love each
other and i agree it wasn't about tasha
last night i actually feel like that
like families coming
100 and like honestly they're all these
guys are like so close especially they
always have
each of them have like one special
person and i thought it was really
really sweet and zacky's hometown his
family was super cute and his dad was
like
hilarious when he was like interrogating
he's like i'm from a small town
i don't know about girls who date four
guys at the same time like it was just
so pure
and i actually feel like um their date
and like their family dynamic like i
think
worked best with tasha yeah i think that
there was like they were having a really
good
fun time yeah then we had oh no i
didn't um who got surprised by his
brother which was like so freaking cute
it was literally like extreme makeover
like surprise like
they never do that no they don't but it
was worth the wait it was so good cute
ivan is a cutie and i stand by what i
said yesterday absolutely nothing about
him
i i just didn't last night and i haven't
in general gotten the vibe that tasha is
like in love with him i feel like she
wants to be around him so much like as a
friend yeah i just don't get that like
sexy
she's like super comfortable around him
and that's why she keeps him around for
so long because you like
like there are people in your life like
regardless of gender who like just make
you feel comfortable and safe and i feel
like that's ivan for her
yeah but i think he is like so head over
heels in love with her he's going to be
crushed i mean everybody is in love with
her yeah
which leads us to our next hometown
which was ben who just like
is such a wussy like he couldn't even
get out that he loved her it's like what
don't go on the show like that's
literally what you do like that's a
formula yeah when it was
the after the hometown that night when
they were sitting on the bench there was
absolutely no reason why he couldn't say
it and he literally just couldn't get it
out and then tasha
when she sent it home she's like i'm
just tired of like pulling things out of
him and that was just such a good reason
like
honestly of all the breakups i've ever
seen on the bachelorette the reason is
always like
we're not there yet like they're always
so big but taysha had such a concrete
reason that i like just
and she verbalized it so well i
respected her so much on the
bachelorette or bachelor like i've never
understood really why it's always
because i like someone else more she was
like no
i like them all equally right now but
like i'm just tired of like having to
pull things out of ben it's like
it's exhausting yeah and it's like he
couldn't and he felt it but he couldn't
say it like
we're too old for this yeah i agree i
mean when she sent him home i think he
was in complete shock when he was in the
car like like that was
genuine like emotional shock like cannot
speak cannot think and so i understand
why when she sent him home
he still had nothing to say because at
that point like he couldn't function
but after the hometowns when he realized
that he loved her like there was no
reason why and and he should be able to
express himself a little better
i agree and i think he's literally going
to regret it for the rest of his life
100
but i did think his hometown with his
sister and their family friend was like
so cute how he had like these two girls
in his life and they're like best
friends i thought it was really sweet
really sweet but also i do feel like
yes tasha's tired of pulling stuff out
of him but she also was not in love with
him because if she was
she wouldn't she would work even harder
like he was not her number one she would
have pulled it out
she yeah like and i just feel like
as much as he didn't give everything
that he should have like
it's not like she sent home her number
one guy no no i wasn't giving her enough
like
that's not what it was i do think like
she also feels stronger about other
people
100 last night's episode while it was
better than
monday night's episode it did honestly
it made me yearn
for claire and her like toxic energy i
just
i was having more fun watching her being
so nuts like
and the guys yo safe like i just missed
that like chaos
and like this is just everything's going
too well i'm like bored yeah no i hear
what you're saying and also like with
claire like
we knew exactly where she stood like
this season any one of the guys could
win
could what even with bet included like
last night i felt like any one of them
could be the winner and i wouldn't be
shocked and i miss like
claire showing us exactly who yeah who's
gonna win and i also just miss like
there was just like every episode
whether it was like the most dramatic or
not with claire there was so much
weirdness to unpack like on
claire's part on the guy's part and i
just missed that like
toxic whirlwind you know yeah but i also
think that is
how the bachelorette always starts when
there are 25 guys including the crazy
and the villain
yeah this and so as it gets more serious
you do lose that weirdness because that
chaotic energy
yeah yeah but i do miss it um all right
so we have the finale next week monday
and tuesday we will not be
on live but um but we'll all
talk about it i mean and there's really
not much i hope that like whoever she
chooses that they're like living in
bliss and i feel like right now they are
because just like tasha's instagram
stories she seems like so happy and yes
living and i'm just like oh she's
definitely engaged to someone she's
absolutely obsessed with and it's just
like
having the time of her life you want to
know why i also think it's sexy
because um tasha was on that new podcast
with hannah anne
okay click bait yeah yeah she hosts it
oh she hosts it
and they were doing a conversation about
dating people who are sober like if
that's something you would be open to is
that something like you
think your lifestyle is good for and ta
and i think hannah anne said that
she doesn't think it would work for her
lifestyle but tasha was like
unequivocally like oh yeah
oh interesting it was a good tasha that
was a good teacher i was also starting
to think about
ben in paradise yes and who i would set
him up with
and i feel like maybe him and hannah ann
have a future
everyone has been just like shipping
hannah and with different people oh yeah
no but i was thinking like who are the
girls maddie we still have
maddie prue not for ben i don't think
she's going on paradise you don't
i think her life is like a tick tockers
and like an auburn alum like queen
is like so good you think yes why
wouldn't she want more
from the source like she got all of that
from being on the bachelor wouldn't she
go back to the source and like get some
more
i don't know i think i think of all the
people
no i'm not gonna say it okay then we
also have kelsey
who we [ __ ] adore stan victoria
fuller even though she's like
been dating around she might be single
but i absolutely love her she'll be a
paradise queen and not to be a freak but
i would just love to see animating suit
like
i just think she's literally the most
beautiful girl in the world like yeah so
i was just like i've been starting to
think about like
who is with who but i also feel like the
paradise couples that come out that are
like
rock solid are never ones that i would
have predicted you never expect
raven and adam gotcha no i thought it
was raven and dean forever forever
um and then we never even expected like
dean and caitlyn to be like okay but
then all of a sudden like here they are
living in a van best friends forever
best friends forever that's our
bachelorette recap and now it's time for
deer toasters our advice segment
where we deliver um decent advice you
would say
i would say top-notch top-notch advice
for all your problems whether it's
relationship problems friend problems
work problems
you know hygiene problems anything so
the email is dear toasters gmail.com
we always keep it anonymous and we'll
scrub out everyone's names so you can
write in safely
first up good morning claude jacks
morning thanks for bringing me the most
premium content
during my treacherous work days and
being beautiful stunning and smart
i'll start by saying my businessman beau
is an absolute p john
and treats me like a literal queen wow
sounds awesome
i love him so much and we've been
married for five years together for
eight
the other day when going through his
closet snooping for my christmas
presents
i found two large amazon boxes hidden in
the back
which contained packs of adult diapers
absolutely shook i started looking at
receipts and these were from the last
three months
i know my husband doesn't need these for
medical problems because we share a bed
every single night
and it's never been an issue i'm so
concerned and confused about what i
found and don't know what to do
he's an extremely professional well put
together man with a wonderful career and
we have a fantastic sex life
i feel completely blindsided by
everything if these are something he
needs i want him to be comfortable
telling me he's my husband
what do i do any advice would be greatly
appreciated sincerely an og toaster
that's tough i don't really
realistically know how you can live with
someone for five to eight years
and hide wearing adult diapers yeah
i think you should just and especially
since you're saying like whatever it is
you are
good with it and you love him as he is
of course i think you should just ask
him and say
um i stumbled upon you have to admit
while you were snooping but i think
that's fine i think your reason for
snooping is cute enough and you say and
they found these diapers like
um what are they for maybe they're for
someone else you just never know don't
assume anything but also and also don't
have like a mocking
like a laughing tone because you're
probably like embarrassed if they are
for him
yeah so i would just like go sweet as
sugar yeah
and say i was just i saw these and i'm
just curious
like i don't know do you take out the
trash in your home you would see adult
diapers like you have to change them
three times a day
there's no way this man has been
literally consistently wearing adult
diapers for eight years and you didn't
know
yeah no maybe he got them for one of his
parents
maybe they're a prank for a friend but i
would definitely like just go
in open and say do you wear diapers
yeah just we need to sew that's okay we
need to not be afraid to ask our
partners things like do you wear diapers
you know it's just we're living in 2020
like just ask
yeah just do it honesty is the best
policy all right next up
hello jackie of course letting the toast
know what he says
is also the best part we would like an
update yeah
dear jackie and claudia happy hump day
let's get right to it
our husbands have had the same group of
friends oh i guess this is from
two people our husbands have had the
same group of best friends since grade
school and put each other over
everything one of their best friends
richard is married and has a baby due in
a month
but let's just say he's not handling
becoming a father too well we learned
from a girl that went to high school
with her husband that richard recently
sent her a dick pic
totally out of the blue they hadn't
talked in years then another girl we
went to high school with
came forward recently saying she had
received her own picture with a
personalized caption
about a time they had hooked up in the
past our husbands have already
brushed both incidents under the rug but
what do we do do we call richard out on
being a total loser go to his wife and
pretend we don't know
help please help with our dilemma oh
this is [ __ ] terrible i hate having
information that like i just don't need
to know you know yeah also it's funny
that you called him richard because of
his dick
yeah i think that was intentional yeah
no it's cute um okay so
let's let's set the scene you have to
put i have to place myself
you are two girls who are husbands who
are
best friends and friends from high
school one of their friends richard
has a baby on the way in sending dick
pics to people i think you got to tell
the wife
but what is your relationship with the
wife probably not that close
and then you're going to like break up
this group of friends
i think it's time for a ron and sam
anonymous note i i know i just wish that
that incident hadn't gone so poorly on
the jersey shore because i think it was
a fantastic idea
but see here's the thing and and i i
don't know if i mentioned actually
recently for like the third time and
re-watching
jersey shore from the beginning um and
that situation
is like a classic pop culture example of
writing an anonymous note and it went so
awry that people are
you know trepidatious trepidations of
doing it but i think that
sam's reaction to it was so
unbelievably wrong and she got so mad
she was so
hell-bent she was more interested in
finding out who wrote the note than
finding out
if what was in it was true and that's
because if you watch you realize now and
why sammy is not a part of this
group anymore and she doesn't do the
reboots it's because ron was literally
the most
abusive mentally like the most
emotionally mentally abusive boyfriend
of all time like the most toxic
relationship like no wonder she was so
you know like [ __ ] up in the head that
she was so crazy about who wrote the
letter
so i feel like we should stop using that
as an example because it's not fair
because she wasn't in the right hands
but i'll say here's the thing if you
obviously you just want her to know the
information but you don't want to
know that it came from you because that
ruins the group dynamic but if you
receive this letter you are
eight months pregnant and you don't know
where it came from you can't
get additional information you can't get
any like context or have anyone to talk
to about it
um i think that's a really terrible idea
i think that
you keep this to yourself like she's
eight months pregnant i don't think she
needs to know this right now
and wait until it's a better time
like if nothing else happens never
mention it if something else happens
hopefully it's at a time where she can
is not pregnant he's not pregnant and
doesn't need this additional stress
and also like on the scale of like
ruining someone's life
like what do we do i just feel like a
dick pic it's like it's a bad thing and
it's really bad it's cheating it's
cheating but like
not worth the upheaval that
will happen for like this new mom well
that's the thing it's like we must
protect the pregnant woman at all costs
so whether or not you want to say
something maybe now is not the time she
said she's eight months pregnant so i
would like wait a few months but no but
if you wait a few months and nothing
else happens there's no more dick pics
maybe richard meets his child and it's
like oh my gosh this is like the meaning
of life
it's just why is our bar why is our bar
so low you know it's like oh richard is
going to turn into a
decent human being when he meets his
child but having a pregnant wife
is not enough i just i'm not saying that
he is going to i'm saying like maybe i'm
trying to give richard like the benefit
of the doubt
but i feel like men like richard don't
deserve the benefit of the doubt and i
want to take no but his wife deserves
the time like i just think
you don't tell her anything now if
nothing else happens ever again you
never tell her anything
if something happens at a time where she
can receive the news better
you can tell her but like right now you
just sit on your hands
oh my god i just flipped to the next
card i'm sorry we have an update
on the girl whose husband eats his
toenails
and how's the divorce going have you met
someone else here guys
we've been waiting for this dear claudia
and jackie i have heard your request for
an update on the show recently and even
on claudia's insta story
so here we go to answer everyone's
burning questions yes my husband is
still a practicing attorney yes we are
still happily married
but believe it or not the sampling of
boogers has
ended the toe biting and earwax smelling
has also ended
we laughed for weeks after that episode
that was all it took
for someone else other than me to call
him out on a podcast that we both love
and after that he uttered the words okay
okay
i'm done now for everyone who doesn't
believe this i've checked the bedside
for a booger wall i've witnessed the
clippers being used on his toes and
q-tip usage has tremendously increased
i've done my due diligence it's done a
changed man so thank you claudia and
jackie
thank you very much with love a very
merry toaster
we are saving lives oh my god i'm so
relieved and humbled to have been of
service to you and your husband and i'm
so happy for you
that is some really good news that's
just the kind of good news we need
in the holiday season and it's our last
week of the shows and i feel like
this is kind of emblematic of like the
really important work that we do here
like changing lives
hearts and minds no i totally agree and
sometimes all you need is a little
perspective
no and you know what she actually made a
good point like sometimes hearing you
know
like hard truths from someone totally
random it's like really the thing that
gets you over the edge
yeah no but also like sometimes you
don't know like
if you've been doing something for so
long you don't know that there's
anything like weird or wrong with it and
then for to have just like two people
who don't know you have
no skin in this game react the way that
we did tells you everything you need to
know
no totally i'm so honored that like we
made such an impact like our work is
important
it's wow dead wow well thank you guys
for writing in the updates if you've
ever written and we
written in and we've given you advice
please write us back we would love to
hear from you we're now two weeks in a
row
with updates which is so exciting cause
we never hear back from our little
our little campers i just assume no news
is good news
yeah you're not writing again it means
everything went well
100 and that's our segment again if you
ever want to write in dear toasters at
gmail.com
always kept anonymous and we'll always
protect you and give you great advice
love it that's all we got you guys
anything you want to say before you wrap
up this hump day
no that's all she wrote thank you guys
so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennial morning show where
we deliver the past five stories that
you need to know every monday through
friday on youtube
so if you're watching us on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we are also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitch or public radio i
have read a cat box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
morning toast leave a five star review
about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are we hope you
have an amazing day you guys and we'll
see you tomorrow
for thursday's show goodbye
you